it's named after Hatton field new jersey
definitely bring his named after it like
there's a town in New Jersey called
Haddonfield so they made up
fictional Haddonfield oh I named gotcha
I digress it cool I guess that's a good
intro as any know this is dead air I'm
Michael Hardy your host
here's always a Mary Kish who's
switching our second ever video episode
like 29th episode but uh we have Tim
Tory from Capcom returning guest you
were here a few months ago it was a
while ago I feel like this yeah this
podcast had just started yeah we were
talking about resin evil seven resonable
in general because but you've since been
bumped up in the Capcom ranks you're now
what's your I'm a associate brand
manager working on Resident Evil very
belated Congrats oh well thanks so much
here and thanks for having me back
yeah and then we have Dan Reichert from
Giant Bomb yes how are you I'm good you
are down the hall from us in the cbsi
building but that is true we figured you
bringing you on because we're talk about
Halloween 1 & 2 we figured this week was
a good one to talk about it and I mean I
didn't want to meet temporary for a
while so nice to meet you sir Stan him
yep very mr. Reichert yeah good to meet
you Dan yeah yeah oh right okay yeah
you watched Halloween 1 & 2 for the
first time we all watched it last
weekend and figured we got a bunch of
different perspectives I've seen them a
few times Tim you've seen him a ton Mary
you're pretty well-versed in the
Halloween movies from what I understand
oh yeah I don't know anyone who isn't I
think that's weird if you have any first
time you'll be weird to like yeah being
a horror podcast or help kind of get one
rolling without yeah having a long
history of that right sure yeah so are
you are you making fun of me because
when did you first see it again it was
right so I saw the first one for the
first time like six years ago
okay but I didn't but then I was I went
out to see you when you live in
Minneapolis last year and we watched it
again that was like my first time as an
adult watching it okay yeah that's right
I mean I was I was an adult six years
ago yeah
aging mice not aging myself doing the
opposite I'm young in myself that's
right by saying that young in yourself
yeah okay I don't know so we all watched
it and I think it was a fun time we all
kind of it was a blend of like oh that's
where that trope came from a know this
is really cheesy now and even in the
last year I think they have bee
more dated in my eyes yeah I mean it was
fun because there was like honestly the
majority of the folks that we had watch
it that you know I've always taken
pleasure in showing people stuff that I
care a lot about like in a very selfish
way but like a lot of people hadn't seen
it and a lot of people really enjoyed it
there'd be the thing where it's like oh
yeah that's such a cliche now and then I
don't know the sound system that Justin
has set up or whatever is just good
enough that it would just pop and people
would scream anyway which was like
heartening to me it was like a
reaffirmation of like oh yeah
Halloween's my favorite horror movie and
this is why yeah is it your favorite
because of its importance to the genre
or in that it set all these tropes and
emotion everything or is it because if
you lay them all into end to end and and
you watch them all for the first time in
2016 do you think it would be better I
think it's like a it's like a double
thing like Halloween was the reason that
I started watching horror so it was like
just to to dump out this story it was
like middle school or something I had
some a friend Josh Wilson middle school
that was like hey Tim you should watch
this movie it's gonna be on like Turner
classics or some old channel I don't
even know if it's still around and I'm
like okay I'll watch it and I remember
distinctly it was like fall it was close
to Halloween
I was watching TV my mom was sitting
over there I was laying on the couch I
fell asleep and woke up all the lights
are off TV was still on it was just the
beginning of Halloween like the like the
very very beginning of it oh so like
Michael Myers going and you know yeah I
mean we can spoil very sensitive about
these kinds of things but anyway and so
I watched it and I made like I remember
making a really just terrible Swanson's
breakfast sandwich and heating that up
and watching all of it just being
terrified like my first real horror
movie just basically traumatized into
loving it for life and then that over
the years just I realized how important
it was I realized it was like a
prototype for slashers and started
watching tons of slashers but I didn't
appreciate it in that moment now I would
watch it every few years and then
solidified how much I loved it okay how
traumatized were you can you still eat
Swanson breakfast sandwiches um no Mira
I can't
I I stopped and that was for a
confluence of reasons as well they never
would get totally warm in the middle
damn she got him in half you do the oven
you can do you can usually do oven or
microwave with these things a little
school I was terrified of the oven is
gonna be whatever knee McAllister
furnace didn't like going in the
basement my dad had an old bully mask
before I even knew what Friday 13th is
all about okay Glen mask was terrifying
but they are inherently sinister
speaking of of Friday 13th came out in
1980 Halloween came out in 1978 and like
before there's lots of like psycho
references and and some direct nods in
Halloween but and there had been
slashers before but all of them were
kind of this grab bag of varying quality
and like I think Halloween goes down in
history as being that prototype for
slashers like Fred xiii like Nightmare
on Elm Street you know Friday Texas
Chainsaw Massacre had existed before and
like I think 76 and then of course
psycho where it's like the references
are really fun and I think you saw some
of them where it's like the first person
camera perspective where you seen
through the eyes of the killer
there is Sam Loomis Loomis is a is a is
a reference to a psycho character and
Sam Loomis is Michael Myers doctor and
then on top of that I think Janet Leigh
is her name who is Jamie Lee Curtis --is
mother is the actress from psycho okay
so and it was Jim Lee Curtis his first
film Halloween was but yeah it's like I
don't know there's all these little
connections and nods and it planted the
roots for just one of the biggest
subgenres of horror it was really
interesting for me to see of the first
time over the weekend because I'm
sitting here thinking like it was maybe
the third horror movie I've ever seen
I've seen my outer space oh great
what can probably they're really messed
up that was probably the first one I
ever saw and I scare the [ __ ] out of me
the second one was probably event
horizon and that wasn't scared the [ __ ]
out of me I screamed three okay and I
think that's the extent to this day of
all the horror movies I've seen it now
how ya seen scream three yes that was
the only one that came out while I was
working at a movie theater but I am a
Film Studies major
so I would agree so I know what I'm
talking about here's your 10 the
techniques being used yeah the other
thing is always interesting to me is
Daniel like you're a huge John Carpenter
fan you love be a little China you like
escape from New York
you had me one too the thing is for you
you have me watch okay thanks
but I mean Tim got me to watch that like
what two years ago for the first time
and it's awesome it's great yeah I mean
it has some like action elements in it
too in the practical effects inside by
yeah but it's it's a horror movie yeah
yeah 100% it's like I think generally
like the top ten usually I'd say I was
just curious to you like the more you
watch horror movies the more like do you
want to watch them more I think so oh
wait sorry real quick I've seen Jason X
but that's important yeah
what is it liquid nitrogen scene where
he we talked about this freezes the
guy's face and liquid nitrogen yeah yeah
uh God what was it so yeah yeah I do
like all these movies that I've seen or
Tim's introduced me to have been a lot
of fun I like them a lot like I've
always been an action movie guy but this
kind of feels similar and that like
here's a bunch of stuff that happens you
know violent stuff and then at the auu
root for the bad guy to get killed at
the end I mean it seems like it's
basically that right except for it seems
like the difference is in action movies
they actually die at the end and from
what I've seen in horror movies they
just come back six times they go to
space that's that's the logical
progression okay yeah I feel like I owe
you in some way I mean he's been showing
you horror movies but you showed me a
bunch of action moves I'd never seen my
I showed you I introduced you to
Terminator 2 and face up and I
introduced Tim to the rocky series so
yeah those are pretty good ones to
introduce people to I think we got a
good like circle going yeah yeah so I'm
just like I'll introduce both you know
romantic comedies and all sweet yeah
complete yeah it makes the
quintessential piece of information for
well yeah oh no I like it yeah sure I
haven't seen black Christmas
incidentally I have not seen black
Christmas so we had a reader email maybe
unlike our 8th episode or something
telling us to watch it and it actually
served as a big influence for Halloween
so black Christmas is 1974 four years
before carpeted at Halloween it's
Canadian and it's set in Montreal the
Westmount neighborhood which I've
actually been to enough I'd the first
time I saw it was right after I had been
there so it was kind of cool confluence
at those things but it actually starts
off very similar to Halloween so it's
about this this murder killing people in
a sorority house and it starts off
through that first person perspective
with the breathing the one thing though
that was tough about Black Christmas
people who listen might know this and
then Pete Brown and I talked about I
have misophonia know if you've heard
about me about this yeah it's sort of
like certain noises can really just
drive you nuts
like chewing or guttural noises so in
Black Christmas the breathing is
accentuated to the point where it's like
this gargling kind of like if you've
seen hay or only you know that one that
held up punches all the time you guys
and watch hey oh I do remember some
voice acting in like only heavy
breathing ones okay only the ones that
require no actual dialogue okay you can
recognize her size and many a
blockbuster film but no the intro to
Black Christmas once you get past that I
actually liked it but there's like some
of those tropes yet the the call is
coming from inside the house actually
it's it's from that so that kind of like
one of the first ones where the killer
was there the whole time
it's awesome inept police that's like
huge in that kind of violence with like
a mix of comedy and a bit of sexual
tension type thing like a lot of that
stuff was was there it's a bit dry and I
think by today's standards a lot of
people would watch black Christmas me
like alright I know where this is going
and they're right but that's because
it's been done a million times since
then it was like okay and then like the
promiscuous girl is the first one to die
from what I remember a black Christmas
actually I think it was the I think it
was like the girl who wasn't adventurous
at all and they were like you're so lame
you're a lame duck and then she went
upstairs and got killed she gets smoked
but I do I also think all the all this
all the sexy ones get killed too of
course that's I'm gonna have to watch it
yeah I want to watch it again it's it's
I like anti Christmas movies to think
that Jean
called the dye anti-crisis that are said
during Christmas okay but they're not
about Christmas very much like oh yeah
because they're all deciding to stay at
the sorority house over Christmas break
instead of going skiing with their
families or something which then those
calendars just has free reign and
whatnot it's worth watching it's it's
dated but it's cool it's Bob Clark
directed it Canadian director
psychologic I don't know anything else
he's done but it was a good movie it was
a good and reader recommendation I have
to check that out it's interesting
because that's another one that's
centralized around a holiday yeah it
sounds like Halloween when it was first
like in its iterations or early
iterations it was called like just the
babysitter murders so it was like
stripped of any Halloween
setting it always Halloween's a better
title right yeah isn't it much better
it's perfect right murdering
babysitter's or babysitter's murdering
their kids no yeah that's a good
question I both sound you go and kill
the babysitter's I think that's don't
tell Mom the babysitter's dead oh that's
right yeah that's honey I murdered the
babysitter he said Rick Moranis and he's
right Bree I would watch that yeah yeah
what were your overall impressions of
like one compared to two because two I
think is acknowledged is going off the
rails in a lot of ways I definitely
liked one better it seemed just more
kind of contained and focused and I get
the two is like okay well we did the
neighborhood thing let's I don't know
Hospital like it makes sense you know
being right after the first one that you
know Jamie Lee Curtis would be in this
hospital or whatever but yeah I if I
gave the first one like a nine or
whatever I'd say this is a solid eight
and there's a second yeah I've seen
Belfair it's like a sequel by the
numbers I feel like and a lot of the
creativity and like the the sort of
weird logic behind Michael Myers is
kills it just seems like it's kind of
out the window it seems like it seems
like it could have been in any slasher
from the 80s you know it didn't really
feel like it was in the same exact theme
is the first one it just something felt
different about it even even though it
was appropriate you know yeah I think
that one was it was at 81 I think was
the sequel yeah I also like that in the
first one because the timeframe that it
takes place in like no one knows that
this is going on that there's this guy
running around killing people so when
people see him and just like what the
[ __ ] is this thing what is going on here
and then by two it's like it's all over
the radio tell
it was like I look out there's a crazy
guy running around and I don't don't
know if that affects any of the scenes
necessarily but I like the idea of like
these characters are like I have no idea
what's going on with this guy
and then he just becomes a legend after
that rest in peace Ben tramer by the way
we played Michael Myers know he was the
guy that got pinned between like the Oh
that wins and they're not concerned
about that when they learn about that's
just some totally innocent traitor
traitor they got horribly burnt to death
Mary brought up like the inept police
which I love that trope I love the
police showing up and getting like like
they're just merely taken out of the
equation in horror movies where just
like that false sense of security but
it's just the sheriff is just falling
around Donald Pleasence is character dr.
Loomis the entire time like alright well
if if while if you're wrong and these
kids die we're staked out the Myers
house for no good reason then it's your
ass like well you're the sheriff well
why is the most effective cop the doctor
yeah exactly why they take orders from
him what is the doctors say at that one
point when someone says some about death
oh you don't know what death is what I
love about that is the punchline of that
too is like right at the beginning of to
where it's like Michael Myers his body's
gone he puts his fingers in the grass he
looks up the blood he's just kind of
like what's going on out here I've been
scared after death tonight and Loomis
just looks something goes you don't know
what death is instead of being with the
really subtle piano version it's like
the point where it's like a super cynthy
like john carpenter's just really into
it this time
that's not even a good line either like
of course he knows what you don't know
pain maybe or like you don't know
Halloween but death you don't know the
movie the film series Halloween says the
doctor who just shot someone six times
and they didn't die yeah seven yeah I'm
seven in the recap of the first one
because there's a blooper where he
accidentally unloads his six-shooter
seven times
Michael is the most noticeable just like
continuity error in movies yeah six
shooter guns like we see that it's yep
revolver don't don't shoot seven times
you even need to lean into it and then
just have it be infinite ammo like a
Gatling got the bandana on heaved Meryl
shut up him but so one interesting thing
between the changes one and two is like
so 78 was carpenter and he wrote and
directed it with Deborah Hill who is why
or it's growing at the time really yeah
her hand actually you know when it's
like the flashback and six-year-old
Michael Myers is reaching for like the
butcher's name yeah that's that's
Deborah Hill they needed some small
hands ok clown suit was she a child with
some weird dialogues with characters in
but uh and then it was like eighty one
where they were approached for the
sequel and I think carpenters along the
lines of like I already did that and so
they wrote and produced it but carpenter
between seventy eight if he had done
escape from New York and the fog and
then 82 was the thing so those are three
of like in like a really short like
three four year period carpenter had
done like four of his most notable films
Wow like the fog I have not seen the
father of I wouldn't Carpenter was
playing in Berkeley or whatever I went
to see him and you showing clips
alongside the music he was playing which
was awesome super cool show I was like I
should probably watch the fog I know
it's not regarded as being that great
but it's like if you found out there was
a Metallica album you'd never listen to
a Skynyrd album I don't know why I'm
thinking of that yeah people watching a
Metallica album that isn't regarded as
that great yeah but but does such a
thing exist that Lou Reed album is great
being okay it's like you have to do your
you know you're just like this is really
gone off the rails basically that's what
it's like it's like if there was a loss
to Wrestlemania
yes exactly yeah it's just like well
even it's not regarded as a good one
right and I got to do your due diligence
and go see it yeah or if there is like a
Zooey Deschanel romantic comedy I hadn't
seen right that's a possible money no
I've seen all of them I don't know if
you want to establish yourself as this
person just totally a joke but I haven't
seen the gilded gilded what waitress
menu book no I'm just trying to think of
a name just I'm swapping out words from
Sisterhood of the Traveling Pants or
something I don't know it gilded the
gilded restaurant menu but
waitress what's a menu button menu truce
is in there somewhere
The Sisterhood of the Traveling of
course a Halloween free issued all of
the the tropes from the first
now Halloween - I like becomes that kind
of just like crazy kill montage yeah the
boiling water with her the girls yeah
yeah when first kills the guy just
strangles it stabs him in the back room
right yes and he turns up just it has a
scalding setting yeah
starving for a bath yeah and like the
weird blood draining thing like it they
all get a little weird I thought about
that someone was like why would Michael
Myers know how to do that and they did
acknowledge in one when Michael Myers
steals the car from Smith's Grove
sanitarium and peels out Loomis brings
it up he's like he's driving a car why
is you know how to do that guys this
should be locked up all the time yeah
but and someone brought that point with
the IV and Halloween - or it's like why
do you know how to do that well I mean
he was in a hospital he probably had a
fair share of IVs stuck into him do they
explain the car thing I don't know they
do so in Halloween six I want to say
curse of Michael Myers
angel' that loophole there's a lot of
like here for once you get to there's a
lot of killing ahead to be done between
those but so the idea is when Loomis is
walking out a Smith's Grove and talking
to that hospital director or whatever
who is like oh how do you learn how to
drive a car that hospital director they
decided it was like I wish bring him
back and he is like one of the leaders
of a cult that helped make Michael Myers
into the embodiment of evil that he is
okay which is another weird thing
according to Halloween one if Michael
Myers killed Judith Myers when he was
six and was hospitalized for 15 years
before he broke out he's 21 like he's a
dead one year old dude but he just like
to me Michael Myers like when I first
watched it and now when I still watch it
it's still just like this cipher like I
don't try to like in my mind try to
figure out what he looks like underneath
the mask and show it though they do they
show it more than I think anyone who
remembers when it's at the end when he's
fighting like Jamie Lee Curtis yeah
channels it off but yeah it's just
interesting because like obviously their
goal is just to have like this blank
slate of evil like project your own
feelings about what this killer is on to
him and like I think that worked really
well and to the point where I don't even
care what he looks like
does does Jason talk I've never seen
that I mean outside Jason X he never
Jason's not meant to talk so so what
separates Jason from like Michael Myers
besides a hockey mask that's a great
question Jason Jason has different
motivations I suppose when you look at
the
Gritty of the tropes right like that
they kill sexy teens and and they're
quiet killers there's a lot there's
there's not as much to to differentiate
right but when you look at the
motivations behind those you know like
Michael Myers was quite as like this
like psycho killer right from the get-go
whereas jason was someone who became a
killer because someone harmed him or
because like the hand he was dealt yeah
like in my I think you're that's exactly
right the way I've always looked at it
is like Jason is like the embodiment of
his mother's vengeance on the camp
counselors that let him die and like oh
so he died as a kid yeah a reanimated
corpse yeah let's let's take a stroll
through memory later you haven't seen
the original Friday the 13th Friday the
13th there is a killer on the loose
killing teens a bunch of camp counselors
but it's it's not Jason Voorhees it's
his mother right that's actually the
huge twist on it is that Jason was
killed because the camp counselors were
too busy considering having sex with one
another than to watch the kids and he
drowns in the lake so she kills all the
people and the big twist is this is a
huge trope to this day right that if
you're like promiscuous teen you're
going to die that originates with threat
Friday the 13th with the concept that
sex was more important than a child
safety what actually had value in that
film but now it's fine I've been watered
down into what it is now which is uh you
know from whiskey with sex leads to
death and some people try to draw that
back to Halloween but Carpenter has been
like it's not about that at all like
he's just like dismissing like it's not
about morality and point out how it's
just like actually you know Jimmy Lee
Curtis is like all these things happen
to her and she's the most like sexually
repressed character and sexually
frustrated right and stabbing people
with these long objects yeah she's also
quite smart right like um I always
considered Halloween to be more about
like how intelligent people deal with
killers whereas a Friday the 13th is
about a bunch of like moronic teens
trying to have sex and Jason's going
after them one by one in Friday the 13th
I root for Jason because he's awesome
and he's killing these morons that I
don't give a [ __ ] about in fact I would
say most the characters in a Friday the
13th are deplorable characters you don't
give a [ __ ] about
but in Halloween you root for Jamie Lee
Curtis right yes March she's interesting
she's got a good head on her shoulders
and you want her to win so it's like yes
the the killer aspect is a little
similar but the motivations and who you
root for quite different okay and on top
of that Michael Myers just wants to kill
his sister like obsessed with her he did
that very oh wait but then we find
another sister yeah and that's Jamie Lee
Curtis Curtis is we find out in the
sequel that is Michael Myers sister and
Frank whatever reason he's obsessed with
killing her and I think they tried to
connect it because he gets obsessed with
like going down the bloodline and like
finding his I think Jane no what I can't
remember his uh nieces name he goes
after his knees and like you just do
they do they get into those motivations
at all because I always kind of just
assumed that Michael Myers was like the
embodiment of insane evil right like he
like doesn't give a [ __ ] about his
family and he wants to kill them whereas
like Jason had these very clear
motivations like you guys left me to die
that's why promiscuous teens much dives
like what are what's Michaels motivation
I said that cult stuff comes it's the
course it's like this weird Vaseline
over the plot was just like cold like
it's like yeah he's he's crazy so the
answer is cold I mean I don't know if
it's about thinning out his bloodline
because there's some value in the blood
to the of the Myers family to the cult
and beyond that I don't really know so
where was Jamie Lee Curtis like through
the ages work out so that she was a baby
when Myers was a kid and killed the
sister like in two Jamie Lee Curtis who
are her parents does she know that her
parents are the Myers like her parents
are the strode 'he's
oh oh right that's her last name Louis
red yeah so did she get adopted like as
a little kid or yes okay so she has no
idea accident or something I think they
are the actual Myers yeah okay and she
got adopted
yeah I'm Jason knows because he even
smelled blood they reckoned it at a
certain point now but anyway I was
always interested in like the hyper
patient guy waiting 15 years to like
just go crazy the Pepe LePew of murder a
guy who like never runs but slowly gets
to him okay yeah those are the creepiest
scenes are like when she's in school and
she looks out the window
he's just just standing there like no
urgency to say I just want to let you
know I'm gonna super kill you it's broad
daylight yeah yeah and that's this thing
outside a car you're driving around for
us standing by the clothesline or around
a hedge yeah that stuff is like the
stuff that's like did I just see that
yeah I love that stuff in horror movies
I'm assuming you haven't seen it follows
then right
no is that the one about you have sex
with some one of them there goes follows
you around and meets you or something
kind of yeah yeah yeah alright if they
play on the whole slow walking killer
things it just slowly follows you so if
you go to like China or something it's
gonna slowly follow you in real time and
get to you or something from what I
understand but the scene where that you
just mentioned when Jamie Lee Curtis
looks out the window sort of happens in
it follows one where she's in that class
in college and she looks out and it's a
wide shot of a bunch of people like on
the quad just playing frisbee and
hanging out but then like if you're
paying attention you see this old lady
in a hospital robe which you might not
see the first shot and then it goes back
to her and she's got a weird look on her
face then it goes back and the lady's
closer walking toward the classroom it's
really critical spokes ya know but I
need to rewatch that I just reminded me
of a someone that when we were watching
the movie someone one of your friends
had said oh this reminds me it follows
seeing as I go who was it Mike who was
it
kool Kat Patrick kulakowski I think yeah
okay I don't know dumb non joke but
maybe show you it follow this dad
actually does don't got an interest yeah
it's good to modern one would be good
also you talking about how you've been
listening to like John Carpenter's lost
means and so yeah like perturbator and
like this eighties synth wave stuff
disasterpiece is the composer follows
which listeners of this podcast know
yeah he came on he did Fez a sound track
oh okay I liked the first time track
line he had a more sinister turn with it
follows was really good yeah we had him
on the show few months ago more sinister
turn it's a good it's good phrase like
yeah so he was like he was one of two
composers we brought in Jason graves two
from dead space tomb raider yeah he did
a lot of things actually but ya know I
have actually always gravitated toward
Friday the 13th over Halloween I think
Halloween is a better film but Friday
13th I agree with Mary I don't like the
people in it that he's killing which
maybe that's why I enjoyed watching that
sure and Irish she's killing but I also
I do think jason has more kind of like
compelling motive
Asians then Michael does they're more
colorful movies was Freddie a man or is
he just a nightmare being he was a
nightmare so Freddie was a man killed by
the community for being a child molester
yes it's meant to be disliked easily I
find it really interesting that they
paint him as a comedian right so in all
the movies he's actually painted in this
comedic light he's got a lot of like
one-liners and people didn't root for
him but at the end of the day that dudes
a child molester so you shouldn't really
root for that guy maybe not so much but
he doesn't have a corporeal is that the
word for Memorial being yeah when he
became a real no they basically like
killed him and when they did that his
being basically was like I'll haunt your
children in their dreams right so it was
kind of like now he is a ghost which is
many many ways what Jason is now so the
everything to in beyond doesn't really
make sense with Friday the 13th because
the point was that the killer was his
mother so everything after that Jason is
just now this undead dude that can't be
killed that can do surreal things like
go into space but if he died when he was
a little kid I know we're gonna have
track of Halloween why is he a giant man
now like that he could grow in the grave
like what happened at the end of the way
way you ate Jason Jason if he was a kid
when he drowned at the end of people at
the end of Friday 13th
I think it's assumed that like he's
risen and like continues his life wait
assumed or like do they show like a hand
bursting out of a grave or something
well he comes out from the bottom of the
lake and kills the final girl from 30 at
the end of the first that's right end of
the first one but it's like she dreamt
it maybe but it happened anyway
yes Sandy Cheeks the kind of bubble
going on down the bottom of the lake
yeah he does like continued old UI
continues growing up but like the actual
events of him coming out of the lake and
attacking her are like it's fuzzy
because it's kind of painted as her
remembering it so how accurately did she
remember it was he actually fully grown
when he came I mean right they did
creative liberties at that point also
like with his form right like I think in
the next one into he kind of looks like
a like a person who had been drowns like
a fully grown man that had drowned like
his face is like all right frankly
I got drowned seeing those pictures yeah
yeah so like that's pretty weird but
then he takes more forms eventually
where he kind of just looks like a
zombie man I think he's at this point he
is a zombie man yeah because he has been
reborn and you shouldn't really think
about it I can turn that off yeah I'd
like to move on okay yeah I don't know
Halloween too especially I mean it was
always as weird I don't think Halloween
to fields as lived in maybe it's cuz
that the hospital just seems vacant the
whole time it sadly it's oddly quiet
there's like three nurses and a bunch of
babies yeah and there's the one nurse
who just stands that one plays all the
time waiting for the call yeah yeah
trying to figure out how to work a
walkie-talkie and what was actually
speaking of inept police really quickly
Oh had to say this earlier I mean in
that movie the guard in the hospital but
also really quick tangent once more
sorry in stranger things I think they
set it up to make you think that the
police she was gonna be inept because
he's like nine times out of ten it's
just the kid went to stay at a friend's
house or so right and then she's like
what about that one other time and any
but then he becomes a pretty cool
character I think yeah but anyway but
yeah the what happened with the guard at
the hospital he just walk right through
the security cameras looking dumpster
and found blood and I don't know if they
show it but like you see him on a hook
or something later all right
the doctor robotnik looking oh he got a
hammer to the head
oh yeah and that's when that's right the
other cop like after Michael Myers walks
through the plate-glass door which is an
office and then a super Terminator II
and then yeah and then they they got him
down and then it's the other cop who's
just like I'm gonna totally check this
guy out and look at him and Stephanie
gets his throat slit but the actually
the rumors some of the rumors about the
next Halloween movie which is gonna be
carpenter again at the helm really yeah
yeah he's coming back holy [ __ ] no it's
gonna I the rumor is that it is
connected like picking up some
characters from like Halloween to like
maybe one of the deputies that lived
becomes sheriff but those are the rumors
yeah he's coming back Wow so yeah is it
does it follow the Rob Zombie ones it
sounds like they're I think that they're
gonna ignore the Rob Zombie one so was
the zombie one the first one was like a
reboot - the first one was the second
zombie one a reboot of redo of Tuesda
sequel to his
it was just his own thing so forgettable
I realized it I just those movies did
nothing really yeah okay
I saw one of them I think it might have
been just the reboot or the sequel
whoever was the first one he did Jason a
striker makes a claim that there is a
remix of the first zombie Halloween
movie that is not just better but like
yeah like worth watching on its own it
remix how like certain scenes cut and
whatnot he said the studio cut a bunch
of stuff and like zombies original cut
was actually really good like Jason I've
heard him to fell okay
Jason's over at Giant Bomb but he's a
big fry yes man yeah I mean oh yeah
horror fan but Friday 13th is the one I
think of and I think oh yeah sure his
like apartment is like littered with
Friday 13 stuff including like weird
memorabilia like Camp Crystal Lake
actual Lake Warner stuff like to that
degree which it's very impressive I'm
very jealous I have a guy of a giant
Jason Voorhees statue that's like three
feet that I really enjoy
you can replace the machete that's in
his hand oh man I have though I have one
of them but it's not quite as big but
you can take his mask off and stuff it's
I love that stuff I can take off yeah
the mask yeah it's a zombie
water water zombie yep the style yeah
here we are again yeah okay Nori's comes
back to water zombie yeah I think this
is an interesting thing to talk about
with Halloween though like even though
Halloween was the prototype and Michael
Myers kind of kicked off the slasher
genre like Jason is far and away more
iconic when people go to like the famous
movie monsters like yeah ashes of the
80s like you go to you go to Friday 13th
because one like so it was Halloween one
in 78 then Halloween 2 and 81 and then
it wasn't until I think 86 that Michael
Myers came back and curse of Michael
Myers
except for like on a TV someone's
watching it so I mean Friday 13th was
just like soaking up all that slasher
yeah
what's the Nightmare on Elm Street
around that same wire it was but I and I
think that Jason's just a little bit
more close to that like huh standard
stock slasher villain I feel like
growing up has someone who didn't watch
them you know growing up in like the
late 80s early 90s I always heard of
Jason and Freddy being the big horror
icons like I was familiar with Michael
like I'd seen the mask and I knew he was
from some horror movie but I had no idea
the order or which one came first
I just thought Freddy and Jason they're
the ones I see everywhere so yeah and I
always like this sounds stupid but when
I heard Michael Myers I thought the
actor because I was like all right right
but I think Halloween like you were
saying came around that formative time
but then it was established by the time
Jason and Freddy rolled around and I
think yeah like you said they kind of
soaked up the fame that Michael might
have Michael or even like that Canadian
black Christmas it kind of stank yes
true but unlike Black Christmas I really
think that the original Halloween stands
the test of time and that's something
that a lot of movies that maybe
established a genre can't do but to this
day if you show Halloween to someone for
the first time they're probably going to
be pretty cool with it they're not going
to leave the movie saying well that was
garbage I knew exactly what was going to
happen you didn't it still surprises you
it's just a it's a good movie on its own
but then it also established a genre
yeah yeah I thought it was great it
almost kind of reminded me in a weird
way of Jaws oh sure in that there's so
much tension just building up like you
know something bad is happening you know
people are gonna die but I mean you
don't see jaws until like well into the
movie like I know you see Michael Myers
a lot and the early parts but [ __ ]
doesn't start hitting the fan right
until like you know the last yeah that's
a good point and I think that the jaws
comparison is apt to because of the
music oh yeah Anders yeah the classic
Halloween theme or the stocking music
like all of it I and the jaws theme is
so iconic and there's like some there's
some connective tissue between like the
stocking music from Halloween and the
jaws theme like so it's like it's
building that tension before before [ __ ]
hits the family you said there's such an
effective like storytelling method that
reminds me of Dracula the original one
Bram Stoker you don't actually meet
Dracula for most of it it's I forget the
main character's name is going up the
hill in the wagon toward the castle yeah
and then like he's hearing stories from
all the variety perform most of it yeah
and then like by the time you meet him
it's been built up so yeah yeah maybe
the reason that I they aged a little bit
every time I see him is the dialogue I
mean it's just the product of you know
these teenage supposed to be what
Illinois girls but it's clear there's
palm trees every once in a while yeah
South Pasadena okay yeah so like pretty
posh yeah la but yeah it's I think like
the one girl who's saying like totally
every time and it doesn't make sense
oh yeah like just as often as I might
say yeah yeah just says totally non-stop
yeah I mean I think that was that
dialogue was written by you know
carpenter and Hill who weren't
adolescents at that time you know she
was a kid with her with her mini hands
weird all the goo Goo's and Gaga's in
there it's oh I also want to point out
that so Halloween came out in 78 budget
was just around $300,000 box office was
seventy million dollars which in 2016
equivalent was is two hundred and sixty
million four weeks of production that's
like that shoot talk took four weeks
that sounds like like like a Blair which
level of budget to you know yeah return
I think that's also why you see so many
people trying to do what it's done like
Blair Witch or like I mean there's I
mean a million slasher styles and that's
because that cheap production can result
in such a blockbuster hit that you that
you end up seeing all these duplicates
these attempts to do what what it had
done yeah according to this Halloween
two had 2.5 million budget yep according
to like he said that originally the
original 320k I don't see the actual box
office box office iPhone was 25 million
- that's the budget of 2.5 and I guess
you're pretty sizable I try to imagine
where that budget went with Halloween -
there's a car crash there's explosions I
mean the setting I think you know the
whole ending in the operating room where
they're turning up the ether and the and
oxygen and stuff and it blows up you
know they had a burn suit they had some
more but still some of it seems it's so
low-key Jamie Lee Curtis probably asked
for a million that's true and down a
pleasant Suze Loomis who was always
taking oh I also read that other people
that were approached to play his doctor
dr. Loomis was a Peter Cushing so grand
moff tarkin
from Star Wars and also
Christopher Lee so Dracula Oh going back
to Dracula yes really just died like
last year it was as well he mentioned it
like turning down Donald Pleasance is or
turning down doctor Loomis's being like
one of the bigger mistakes of his career
we did a Wicker Man episode a couple
weeks ago he was the he was the bad dude
most original Wicker that's right the
Scottish one so Loomis totally dies at
the end of two right because he's right
there when that explosion
Donald Pleasance comes back and he stars
alongside Paul Rudd in Halloween six as
the same guy Myers you bet center of an
explosion
six is back man but I got those gaps
yeah I kind of get how like Michael
Myers like okay whatever they read Cohn
stuff and now he's a supernatural evil
whatever he can't die but he's just a
little bald doctor like he can't survive
explosions he's Blofeld man I mean oh
right right he comes back I can't go
away like that not that easy Wow
yeah those movies I'll keep watching
them especially one like every year at
Halloween it's man it's it's up there
top top five top three for me we should
watch black Christmas and the fog yeah
watch like it follows and then after
you've watched like maybe 20 horror
movies watch cabin in the woods I saw
that oh you actually yeah you told me to
watch that Tim yeah and actually I liked
that a lot
no context for you but I saw what they
were doing
yeah I knew enough to Roz Moses that
like when they got to the end and all
that stuff was going on I was like oh
that's a cool thing that they're doing
or even without all that knowledge or
whatever sure also worth mentioning just
since this is a GameSpot podcast that I
haven't played it yet but the dead by
daylight yeah Halloween DLC that came
out I really want to check that out sure
yeah I think we're planning on doing
something with that that's a really it's
a fun game it's kind of a janky in a few
ways pretty fun I can't wait for the
Friday the 13th game either yeah you
guys have seen the latest trailer
there's some really brutal finishing
moves because you or Jason and you can
kill these camp counselors and they're
pretty slow so it's like putting someone
into a fire time who's like unflinching
yeah it's pretty aggressive because
they're all mocap I like Kane Hodder who
was like the iconic
Jason actor oh cool and and then there's
also Dylan called last year which is
like another asymmetrical horror game
like these are all like dream horror
games that I
for multiplayer I think they were always
like technically limited because a lot
of these things you don't just want to
be a counsellor avoiding him you want to
be the killer but to just straight-up
kill AI all the time is probably quite
dull so it required asymmetrical
multiplayer which is something that's
really started to become popularized
yeah and is more technically feasible
right now there's a couple horror games
in the horizon I mean actually not many
I think of outlast 2 and that's about it
it's like you know I've really trying to
really dig deep and try to think of a
single other big horror game I don't
think there are any not for years at
least no man routine finally got my teen
looks really good they just released
their new trailer have you guys seen
that I didn't see that
I've been following around a spaceship
some shits going down it looks really
good
oh oh res evil 7 thank you Mary yeah
well yeah but I mean I it is connected
to the conversation of Halloween like I
feel like you know you're running from
nemesis throughout all of Resident Evil
three I think that's a mechanic that
wouldn't exist if it wasn't for like the
persistent you know killer from from
slasher movies we released some gameplay
gameplay clips of residence 7 online one
of them shows Jack Baker
you know player taking him down and you
know you think you got him and you turn
around and he's getting back up and
that's something that I feel like
wouldn't exist in horror as broadly if
it wasn't for something like Halloween
so that line is connected there resin go
six or resin go six I became it like
residue 7 January 24th okay next year
yeah yeah anyway that is all the time we
have today Dan thanks so much for coming
out for the first time and we'll keep
feeding you horror movies so you can
come on yes I'd like to I mean I really
really enjoyed those movies that was a
great time so I yeah I be fine I'm Oprah
more give a fresh perspective yes yes
Tim Terry thanks for coming on again
we'll try get you on more often as well
always a pleasure
Mary thanks for switching and as usual
being co-host as usual email us dead air
at GameSpot if you have questions
comments concerns suggestions for movies
to watch games to play and we'll do our
best to follow up on those and go to
iTunes review us if you feel like it
again if you give us anything less than
5 stars don't bother just kidding
anyway that is all the time we have for
this week so we'll see you next week